[Musica]
vi siete mai chiesti cosa succede nel
vostro cervello quando entrate in un
negozio per comprare un paio d'occhiali
quando vi trovate davanti allo specchio
quello che vi aspettate e di apparire
più belli perché il volto e il nostro
primo biglietto da visita è lo strumento
con cui comunichiamo con gli altri
giusto c'è quindi una grande aspettativa
nello sviluppo di questo prodotto di
essere in grado di portare una
sensazione di benessere
abbiamo affrontato un progetto per
cercare di portare un percorso di
miglioramento nella qualità della vita
delle persone
il caso dell'occhialeria è un esempio
della capacità che abbiamo noi italiani
di trasformare le materie prime in
prodotti che generano sensazioni di
soddisfazione di felicità alla fine è il
concetto della bellezza nel senso più
ampio
pensate ad esempio alla musica all'arte
al cibo
in natura ci sono tre colori
fondamentali guardate cosa ha saputo
fare michelangelo con questi colori o
cosa ha saputo fare con un singolo pezzo
di marmo mi ha sempre affascinato la
capacità dell'uomo artigiano di saper
trasferire il pensiero le emozioni nel
prodotto nel saper creare questo filo
rosso continuo che unisce appunto il
pensiero
l'azione la materia che diventa prodotto
e poi si trasferisce agli altri sotto
forma di sensazioni di tatto di pensiero
e diventa emozione un'altra volta
in tutto quello che noi facciamo
possiamo essere creatori del bello o del
brutto quindi abbiamo una grossa
responsabilità nel 2013 ci siamo trovati
sul tavolo un oggetto all'epoca molto
atteso ve lo ricorderete i google grassi
potete immaginare l'emozione nostra
nell'aprire questa scatola che arriva
dagli stati uniti con questo gioiello
tecnologico dentro però vi dico
rapidamente all'eccitazione è subentrata
la delusione perché non funzionava
perché abbiamo capito che quel progetto
era nato per aumentare il traffico di
dati nelle piattaforme cloud di google
un progetto nato con l'obiettivo di
favorire il business dell'azienda non di
migliorare la qualità della vita delle
persone ma la delusione c'è anche
lasciato un seme dentro il desiderio di
scoprire se si poteva interpretare la
tecnologia in una visione umanistica
dello sviluppo del prodotto mettendo
l'uomo al centro l'idea di creare un
prodotto una soluzione che migliorasse
la qualità della vita delle persone ma
senza compromessi sulle funzioni
fondamentali dell'occhiale
quindi aumentare la percezione della
bellezza proteggere gli occhi dal sole e
correggere la vista e forse in questo
passaggio qui abbiamo avuto
un'intuizione originale quello di
invertire il flusso delle informazioni
quello che noi oggi chiamiamo all inside
out quindi non un dispositivo che
sovraccaricano ulteriormente la quantità
di dati a cui siamo già soggetti tutti
quanti nella vita quotidiana ma il
contrario che sapesse estrarre dati
ricchi e preziosi che sono già dentro al
nostro cervello e li elaborasse in
maniera da creare un percorso di
miglioramento e di benessere nel nostro
cervello ci sono 80 miliardi di neuroni
quando questi neuroni comunicano
emettono delle onde elettromagnetiche
che possiamo misurare con
l'elettroencefalogramma le neuroscienze
poi ci dicono che ad ogni frequenza
specifica delle onde elettromagnetiche
corrisponde lo stato d'animo della
persona quindi alle onde alfa
corrisponde il rilassamento alle onde
beta corrisponde l'attenzione alle onde
gamma corrisponde e riposo e così via
quindi possiamo capire dalle onde
elettromagnetiche lo stato d'animo della
persona e quindi possiamo intervenire
perché ricordiamoci che il cervello
agisce in maniera dinamica e plastica
cioè come un muscolo con l'esercizio
fisico si può tonificare e mantenere nel
tempo altrettanto le capacità di
elaborazione del cervello possono essere
rafforzate ed educate per avere
prestazioni migliori negli stati uniti
ci sono 20 milioni di studenti
universitari 10,5 milioni più della metà
e sotto trattamento farmacologico per
disturbi legati allo stress
in europa la statistica è molto simile
l'unica differenza è che noi per cultura
all approccio farmacologico preferiamo
il supporto psicologico
d'altra parte tutti siamo stati a scuola
tutti sappiamo quanto faticoso sia
prepara
quanto faticoso sia studiare quanto
stressante possa essere passare un esame
e allora non sarebbe bello se potessimo
avere una soluzione un dispositivo un
aiuto che ci aiutasse a educare il
nostro cervello a utilizzare l'energia a
fare questa fatica in maniera più
efficiente e affrontare lo stesso lo
stress in maniera più salutare un atleta
l'inizio di una gara un chirurgo prima
di un'operazione importante o vigili del
fuoco prima di all'interno di una
situazione pericolosa o piuttosto
pensate a situazione più quotidiane un
imprenditore che deve prendere una
decisione di tale per la sua azienda
avete sentito avete percepito sensazione
lo stress e la fatica psicologica
però ci sono anche situazioni più
semplice immaginate l'autista di uno
scuolabus che porta i bambini alla
mattina cosa avrà in testa sarà sereno
sarà concentrato sarà attento come ci
aspettiamo che sia in quella situazione
e questo è lo scopo del progetto safilo
hicks vi lascio condividendo un sogno il
sogno di riuscire un giorno a leggere
l'atto creativo c'è il segnale emesso
dal cervello nel momento in cui genera
un idea innovativa e magari imparare
come coltivare e sviluppare questa
questo talento questa qualità perché la
creatività è l'origine dell'evoluzione
ma è anche quell ingrediente segreto di
noi italiani che nessuna intelligenza
artificiale
riuscirà mai ad imitare grazie
[Applauso]